moving on
our main story tonight concerns land
specifically
the history of race and land ownership
in america a history that has
many horrifying chapters pretty much
from chapter one when america was
discovered from under other people's
feet in fact it has so
many horrified chapters that some have
nearly been forgotten like this piece of
local history
that recently made the news in manhattan
beach california
a house on the sand can cost up to 20
million dollars
and anthony bruce's family used to own
two ocean front lots
i should be a millionaire standing here
talking to you today
more than 100 years ago his great great
willa and charles bruce bought the land
for about twelve hundred dollars
they built a resort called bruce's lodge
the klu klux klan
was involved in harassing them they
burned a cross right out here
and when that didn't drive him away the
city government
decided to take the property
under the guise of eminent domain wow
so when the cross-burning didn't drive
the bruises out of town the city
called in a lawyer to finish the job and
that tells you a lot about how racism in
america works
sure the vigilante racists are spooky
but you've really got to worry when the
with advanced degrees show
up
what manhattan beach did to the bruce
family was clearly unforgivable and to
its credit
the city seems to be trying to reckon
with how to deal with what happened
although
it is also placing some pretty hard
limits on that reckoning
the council did authorize spending three
hundred fifty thousand dollars on art to
commemorate the family
and this week voted to acknowledge and
condemn what happened
but chose not to offer an official
apology it's awful
it's wrong we're not that community now
i wouldn't live here if we were a racist
community and my friends and neighbors
would not live here as well
okay a couple of things there first
manhattan beach's population is only
0.5 percent black so even if you are not
that community now you don't
look unlike it and second if you took
something worth 20 million
dollars 350 000 just doesn't cover it
especially when none of that money went
toward the family you stole it from
there is pretty obviously only two ways
of making this right
give the bruces 20 million dollars or
give them their land back
and incredibly the latter might actually
happen
because la county which owns the land
recently released a plan
for returning it to the bruises which is
to put it mildly about time
it's literally been called bruce's beach
since 2006.
is the apostrophe s a joke to
you people
it indicates possession so
the story of bruce's beach might
actually end with something approaching
justice
land was taken away land is given
back and i want you to keep the elegance
of that solution in mind
as we talk about a far more insidious
and widespread form of wealth
appropriation and that is
housing discrimination there is a long
history of it in america and we will get
to that in a minute but before we do
let's just start with its effects
currently only 45 percent of black
householders
own their homes compared with nearly 74
of whites and since homeownership is a
key component of wealth
it is no surprise that the wealth gap
between white and black families
is so huge many literally don't
comprehend it
one recent survey found that most people
think that for every hundred dollars
in wealth held by a white family a black
family has 90 dollars when the truth is
it's actually closer to 13
with the median white family having a
net worth of around 188
000 and the median black family having
just over
24 000 but the effects of housing
discrimination go well beyond wealth
because
questions about where your house is and
how much it is worth
impact so many things about your quality
of life
for instance because a key way americans
pay for public schools is through
property taxes
better homes lead to better schools
better teachers
and more resources which in turn leads
back to better neighborhoods in general
including cleaner streets cleaner air
and crucially
only the most exclusive and
trees is that tree a bakery
because it's got cakes that tree don't
just let the audio of this play in the
background while you're working click
back on the youtube tab and look at me
that tree can get it so if it has led to
a wealth gap this massive and
consequences this wide ranging tonight
let's take a look at housing
discrimination the damage it has done
and more importantly what we can do
about it some of you
may already know what the last part is
going to be and might even currently be
shouting out your screens but please
don't spoil it for everybody else
let's let it be a surprise and let's
start in the early 20th century because
that is when the real estate industry
really began to grow and as it did
white people moved quickly to codify the
distance between them
and black people one major way this
happened was through
racial covenants essentially bylaws
written into deeds or neighborhood
regulations
forbidding the sale of a house to a
non-white person and incredibly
these covenants were so widespread that
many are still technically on the books
a texas news station recently unearthed
one in a local suburb
and showed it to unsuspecting residents
there section 2 page 3
reads none of the lots shall be conveyed
leased or occupied
by any person other than of the
caucasian race
it provides an exception for those
employed as servants the person other
than
the caucasian race okay
well quite the tone of that okay
is usually reserved for a few things
finding out your grandma is still
sending nudes
that jeremy piven launched a podcast
called how you live in
j piven and that your neighborhood
technically still has bylaws prohibiting
black people from living there
and while racial covenants were done at
the local level what really
turbo charged segregation was when the
federal government got involved
in the 1930s the new deal established
the federal housing administration and
the homeowner's loan corporation or hulk
which is incidentally also
french for hulk uh
the idea of these two agencies was to
make it easier for people to buy
and retain houses during the great
depression and they were promoted at the
time
through newsreels like this this couple
is going through a model house now
suppose we follow them the husband
apparently isn't very keen about it all
but you know how wives are
this cheerful room with its many handy
cabinets impresses even this skeptic
and his wife is entranced by the modern
flat top stove
too bad they can't afford it ah but
maybe they can
for according to this sign they can buy
this house with monthly payments that
are less than they now spend for rent
wow that is a very affordable house for
two people that clearly do not get along
you know how husbands are they hate
their wives and anything that would make
her happy
every moment with them is torture and
maybe a new house would help us neither
of them will leave this wretched
marriage because it's the 1930s
it's up to the baby to save them the
pitch was that the government
would insure your loan so that banks
would accept a significantly smaller
down payment that was standard at the
time with
much lower interest rates and give you
decades to pay it off
the federal government essentially
invented the modern home mortgage and it
worked incredibly well
millions bought homes who could
otherwise never have afforded them
beginning
a cycle of stable generational wealth
that continues to this day
it was a great idea i cannot stress that
enough
which is why it is so tragic that built
directly into that plan
was the intentional exclusion of black
people for instance
hulk developed maps that colour-coded
areas green yellow blue
or red based on their credit worthiness
a neighborhood could earn a red color or
be
redlined if any african americans lived
in it at all
at which point the area would
essentially be ineligible for any
mortgages
meanwhile when it came to new
developments the fha's underwriting
manual essentially mandated
that communities have racially
restrictive covenants as a prerequisite
to receive mortgage insurance these
policies alone
had a devastating effect on black
communities significantly expanding and
locking in segregation
and some developers ensured that they
would continue to qualify for loans
by going to some ridiculous lengths here
in detroit
there was a developer that wanted to
build a development for whites
and they want to get fha loans and
the federal government said you know
what there's a black community kind of
close by
you don't get the good loans and so the
developer
in an effort to try to fix that built a
six foot tall wall
a foot deep to separate the black
community from the emerging white
community
and then the federal government gave the
loan that's
terrible and what makes it somehow worse
is that that wall was
only six feet tall that's just not that
tall it's like the height of a fridge or
a mattress
or snoop dog snoop 6'4 he could very
easily see
over that wall is that what you want
snoop making direct
eye contact with you over your stupid
racist wall how is that helping
anyone and all of this is obviously
horrifying
white people basically wrote black
people can't live here on pieces of
paper
and the federal government said if you
white people don't have one of those
pieces of paper
you can't get a loan if everything had
just stopped there
the damage already would have been
immense but
it very much did not stop there after
world war ii the gi bill
gave returning service members access to
home loans with as little as no
down payment which is great but
the vast majority of financial
institutions still refuse to approve
loans for african americans meaning that
black service members returned home only
to be shut
out of home ownership in the rapidly
expanding suburbs
one of the most famous examples of which
was levittown
a development on long island of over 17
homes and to ensure government support
to build them the developer had the
contract state that
the home could not be used or occupied
by any person other than
members of the caucasian race and when
black people did
try to buy homes there they were told in
no uncertain terms
just how unwelcome they were as this
woman remembers
we went to the office where the
gentleman was showing the houses
so my husband said to him my wife and i
interested in
you know purchasing a home here in
levertown
he said get your out of here
wow that is a sweet lady recounting an
appalling story in just the most
matter-of-fact way but i guess for black
people in america
you ask your grandma to tell you a
wholesome story about something like
the first school dance she went to or
how she and grandpa bought a house
and it's not long before you're suddenly
in the middle of an august wilson play
and crucially white people who were able
to buy homes in levertown
could accumulate massive wealth in 1948
homes there sold for around eight
thousand dollars or about 75 000
in today's money and they currently sell
for 350
000 or more meaning families who bought
homes back in 1948
gained more than two hundred thousand
dollars in wealth
that is a lot so quick side note if you
are young
white and looking for a real return on
investment forget about your amc and
gamestop stonks
what you really want to do is get a time
machine travel back to the 1940s and buy
a house in the segregated suburb
it's the safest investment you'll ever
make and levittown and detroit were by
no means alone this happened again
and again so much so that the exclusion
of black people from these federal
programs
was nearly absolute for instance a
survey of 13 cities in mississippi in
1947 found that
of the more than 3 200 loans given to
returning veterans under the gi bill
only two went to african americans
and nationwide in just the first quarter
century of the federal housing
administration
the government insured over 40 billion
dollars in loans
that is the equivalent of nearly 400
billion today
but some estimates indicate that 98
of them went to white americans 98
if you ate 98 of someone's cannoli
you basically ate all their cannoli
pointing out the fact that they've still
technically got two percent somehow
makes it worse
and the implications of all of this can
be hard for some to think about
earlier this year cbs's tony decouple
did a story about his grandparents
hometown of lindhurst new jersey
and in doing so broke some difficult
news to the town's unofficial historian
wait a minute you're telling me they
were only going to mortgage white people
yeah yeah for you to say that lynhurst
is the way it is because
it almost implies that leonardus was
racist no this is my family too i'm not
saying that
i'm saying that we i'm saying we had no
idea you're right
most people would not have known that
the federal government had this program
in place
okay first i get that this is
uncomfortable but
i will say if a white person says that
almost implies
blank was racist and another one says no
no this is my family too
that doesn't mean the matter is closed
if two white people
are trying to figure out if something is
racist nine times out of ten
it probably is as for that man's claim
most people would not have known this
program was in place just
hold on there because none of this was a
secret at the time
the link between the racial makeup of
your neighborhood and
the value of your home was so well
established
some speculators took advantage of it to
buy homes on the cheap
through a practice called blockbusting
that is where they would go to a white
neighborhood and make it seem
like black people were moving in they
would hire a black woman to
walk up and down the street with a
stroller or call homes
and ask to speak to someone with a
stereotypically black name
the idea was that simply by doing this
the speculators could panic
white homeowners into selling their
homes at a loss
this tactic was incredibly effective but
i will say
some white homeowners did stand firm
like this amazing
woman in baltimore well i had to be
sitting on the steps with a friend of
mine
and the man that had gotten the house
from the woman next door
he came up and he said to me would you
like to sell
and i said no i couldn't afford to sell
because i can't afford to go anywhere
else
and he said you won't sell i said no
he says well pardon me angie these are
not my words
he said what are you going to do when
these move in here and they get out in a
porch in the summer and they drink beer
i said hell i'm gonna join them look
i know this story is full of terrible
people and
unmitigated racism so we should probably
take a moment to celebrate a lady
who just wanted to get drunk on her
porch with her neighbors regardless of
their color
i love so many things about that i love
roses
don't give a energy but also
angie's
rose is gonna rose response because when
roe said pardon me angie
these are not my words that was for us
angie knew
she knows who rose is and she's made
peace with it these women have talked
there is a history in that relationship
bless you rose
and bless angie too just because rose
was an ally
doesn't mean she was always an easy
person to be around
and when you put all of this together it
is no wonder that by the late 60s
fair housing had become a core issue for
the civil rights movement
martin luther king's efforts to combat
housing discrimination in chicago
were met with fierce resistance and
uprisings began to break out
across the country unrest that reached a
fever pitch
in the wake of king's assassination lbj
and congressional leaders
tried to settle things down with the
civil rights act of 1968 with sections 8
and 9
being the fair housing act and section
titled civil obedience and anti-riot act
which is a
pretty effective way of saying that's
our final offer we've gone about as far
as we're going
with this whole civil rights thing the
fair housing act
made housing discrimination illegal and
also required the government to
affirmatively further
fair housing in other words take an
active role in
integration and to his credit nixon's
housing secretary george romney
mitt's dad actually did try to do that
and developed a program
to withhold federal grants from
communities that refused to
integrate but nixon then quickly stepped
in
calling it off and publicly repudiating
the whole plan
concerning governor romney's plan to
what extent should the federal
government
use its leverage to promote racial
integration
in suburban housing it is not the policy
of this government
to use the power of the federal
government
or federal funds in any other way in
ways
not required by the law for forced
integration of the suburbs i
believe that forced integration of the
suburbs is not in the national interest
yeah not great and it is worth reminding
yourself once in a while just how
deeply weird nixon was he's been
rendered so silly by a lifetime of
cartoonish impressions
it is genuinely unsettling to watch him
make unyielding eye contact while saying
i believe that forced integration of the
suburbs is not in the national interest
like a cold robot powered by racism all
i'm saying is
it really says something that the most
human version of nixon is the one where
he's a cartoon head in a jar
and what nixon made very clear there is
that the federal government
would not step in to integrate
neighborhoods meaning
neighborhoods weren't going to integrate
prices in white neighborhoods were now
too high and
the racial wealth gap was firmly
entrenched and even though
overt discrimination was now illegal
there were
and still are many many ways for
neighborhoods to keep themselves white
sometimes it's through zoning like
requiring minimum lot sizes or
banning multi-family homes and sometimes
it comes in the form of realtors
steering buyers away from certain
neighborhoods on a racial basis
they are not supposed to do that but it
still happens
all the time a few years ago newsday had
testers of multiple races posed as home
buyers on long island and the black
testers
experienced disparate treatment nearly
half the time
in some cases they were sent to vastly
different neighborhoods but even a
realtor who news they said
gave out similar listings to black and
white buyers thereby
staying outside the legal definition of
steering
accompanied them with some not so subtle
tips
that she only gave to the white tester
and there's pockets
for jeff too that you know
uh down by the train there's like an
area there
what i say is always to women follow the
school bus
you know that's what i always say follow
see the moms that are hanging out on the
corners there was one fella who was like
insisted on this house
and the wife was pregnant had a little
one and i said to him
i can't say anything but i encourage you
i want you to go there at 10 o'clock
at night with your wife and my doctors
go to that 7-eleven
they didn't buy that no that's
great i have to say without saying it
you know you have the knowledge of the
areas yeah
i don't want to use the word steer but i
try to i use one word
in the areas you know oh well that's all
right then
as long as you don't say the word steer
it's okay
it's like taboo as long as you don't say
one of the five words on the card you're
completely in the clear
at every step of the process black home
buyers are faced with discrimination
a few years ago reporters crunched
through 31 million
loan applications and found that african
americans continue to be routinely
denied conventional mortgage loans
at much higher rates even controlling
the income
loan amount and neighborhood and even if
you own your home
the simple act of having it appraised
can still be tainted by discrimination
this woman had a home appraised twice
but the values seemed
low to her so she did a little
experiment
i met with two of my girlfriends both
are married to white men and i was like
okay i need to borrow one of your
husbands
when the third appraiser came duffy was
gone her friend's husband
posed as her brother the result duffy's
home was appraised for 259
thousand dollars more than double that
of her previous two appraisals
i screamed with joy i just was
i was so elated and then it just
it quickly dissipated and then
i just cried
because this is an actual there it is
in that i'm the thing that's devaluing
my house
look that is just awful we all know
the only time the addition of a white
man should increase value to anything
is if that thing is a movie and that
white man is stanley tucci otherwise
it is just not okay and when you take
all of this together the redlining the
blockbusting
the steering and not least the federal
government's involvement
it all becomes clear that the myth of
white americans post-war prosperity
powered by ingenuity and self-reliance
leaves
a lot out and the problem is there are
many white people who are unwilling to
acknowledge this
or even if they do are unsure what to do
with the information
remember tony decouple's story about
lindhurst the mayor there
and the historian had very different
reactions to what they were learning
the one thing that i'm struggling with
and this is as
as somebody whose family came through
here
is when i looked at the old maps just
over the river
the areas were redlined by the federal
government
meaning they weren't worthy of mortgages
and lynhurst wasn't redlined what do you
do with that knowledge
you move on come on it's all god's
people
now that we do know right what do we do
about it
you know that's a good question i don't
have the answer to that tony i wish i
did
okay we'll get to the content of what
they're saying in a second but first
i gotta know everything about that mayor
and how he came into office
if i had to guess a couple of candidates
disappeared
you can't have a runoff if only one
candidate is on the ballot can you
but as nice as it sounds to just move on
that is not dealing with the underlying
injury here because
even if you had a magic wand and were
able to stop
every facet of housing discrimination
going forward
you still wouldn't be undoing the damage
that has been done
home prices have risen much more than
wages in the last 50 years so
buying a home today doesn't carry the
same economic promise as it did when the
fha
started in fact by one estimate if we do
do nothing and move on it would take 200
years
for the wealth gap to disappear on its
own and yet
so often efforts to address the legacy
of housing discrimination
have been resolutely colorblind here is
joe biden
on the campaign trail just last year my
plan
for african americans will to close the
wealth gap is to invest
in african american home ownership that
includes my insisting that
there will be a fifteen thousand 000
first time home buyer tax credit
for everyone well hold on there joe
for everyone that might sound great but
it also
fundamentally dilutes what you're
actually trying to achieve here
because we've immediately gone from
targeted investment in black home
ownership
to a broad tax credit for everybody and
we sure do
suddenly seem to become a rainbow
coalition just as soon as the federal
government starts handing out cash don't
we
and our failure to effectively target
solutions
based on race has doomed potential fixes
in the past
in the 70s we passed the community
reinvestment act requiring banks
to approve loans in low-income
neighborhoods but
we didn't specify who the loans had to
go to
with one analysis in philadelphia
showing that banks and lenders
favored white borrowers even in majority
black neighborhoods making
this well-meaning act basically a
gentrification machine
although not a literal gentrification
machine of course because as we all know
those are obviously e-scooters so that
approach of
move on we're all god's people hasn't
fixed the problem but
what about that second guy who said he
doesn't know what we should do about it
but wishes he had the answer if that is
true
if he honestly wants to know what a
major component of the answer
should probably be i've actually got
some good news for him because it exists
it's pretty straightforward and it's the
same answer that many black viewers have
been shouting at this screen
for the last 20 minutes because it's
reparations
and the first thing to say about this is
that it's by no means a new argument
people have been making the case for
reparations for generations and the
history
of housing discrimination specifically
made up a large part of tanacy cults's
award-winning essay the case for
reparations seven
years ago and yet even though
reparations are clearly
necessary practical and the right thing
to do
a poll recently found only one in 10
white people
favor them and some dismiss the subject
right out of hand yeah i don't think
reparations for something that happened
150 years ago for whom none of us
currently living are responsible
is a good idea uh we've
you know tried to deal with our original
sin of slavery by fighting a civil war
by passing
landmark civil rights legislation we've
elected an
african-american president i think
we're always a work in progress in this
country
but no one currently alive
was responsible for that wow
reparations aren't a good idea because
we've elected an african-american
president
who exactly is the we in that sentence
mitch
because as i remember it electing that
president was basically your least
favorite thing america ever did
and you failed to devote every waking
moment to making sure it didn't happen
again
we tried to deal with our original sin
of slavery by fighting a civil war
which i didn't have to take a side in by
passing civil rights legislation which i
didn't have to take a position on
and by electing an african-american
president who i've always been against
this country has come a long way and
with god as my witness it will not go
any further but the thing is we're not
actually talking about reparations for
slavery here we should but that is a
different conversation
we're talking about housing
discrimination
mitch mcconnell was born in 1942
the fair housing act wasn't passed until
1968.
this is quantifiable harm done in our
lifetimes
to people who are still alive as for
what
reparations could look like there was a
bill introduced in the house for 30
years by the late john conyers
to form a commission to study this and
this year the house judiciary committee
finally voted to advance it so if we
really want to know
what reparations could look like we can
pass that bill and find out but to be
clear we don't really need to study the
weather at this point we just need to
study the how
because we know what the government did
and we know
the effect it had and there are
potential models for us to learn from
from germany paying reparations to
holocaust survivors to the u.s
paying japanese americans who were
interned during world war ii
and if you are looking for more recent
examples evanston illinois
recently voted to use revenue from legal
weed to provide grants to assist black
people who live there from 1919 to 1969
and their descendants now does that
program fix everything though
of course not its first phase makes
available up to 25 000
for each participant who can only spend
that money on buying or renovating a
house or paying down their mortgage and
the initial budget for the program
is only four hundred thousand dollars so
it might well be limited
to 16 people but it is at least a
real attempt to both acknowledge and
redress
harm and ultimately this isn't something
cities or even states can do
on their own it took the power and
resources of the federal government
to enforce racism on this scale and only
the federal government can truly grapple
with the consequences
and there are some like nicole hannah
jones who have some pretty specific
ideas on what that grappling could look
like
so to me reparations has to be
three-pronged
uh recommitment to strong enforcement of
civil rights laws
because you can get this economic
payment but we know that black people
still face discrimination in every
aspect of american society
and then i think there needs to be a
really large investment
of resources into the black communities
that have had
that wealth extracted and have been
denied the ability to
live like other americans and i think
anyone who's arguing for reparations
that
is not arguing for a cash payment is um
basically that's racist you know because
it's like it's only when it comes to
black folks that we're so concerned
of how people are going to know if they
know how to spend that money
responsibly i say this jokingly but half
jokingly like if if i wanted to spend my
reparations on all gucci
that's my right yeah black people should
get to decide how to spend the money the
federal government gives them
in the same way that white people got to
decide how to spend all the billions of
dollars in wealth
that it created for them i promise you
not all that money has been spent
responsibly
just think of how much of it has gone
towards thomas kincaid paintings
there is one and only one good reason to
buy a thomas kincaid painting and that
is
to help convince the appraiser that your
friend's white husband really does live
in this house
that is it and i'm not saying that money
alone is what is called for here
as nicole hannah jones pointed out
simply handing out cash
without changing any of the underlying
structural conditions that produced
inequality in the first place
would be a big mistake this is a both
and
situation but ultimately the only really
strange thing
about paying reparations to black people
is that we haven't done it yet
just like its strength it has taken so
long to give bruce's beach
back to the bruces in both cases the
right
thing to do couldn't be clearer when you
deprive somebody of something
you make it right by paying what you owe
now
figuring out exactly how to pay might
well get complicated but realizing that
you have to
should be pretty simple because this is
a wound that we are actively choosing
not to heal
and it is hurting real people every day
and also try and think of the positives
here because if we do
choose to do the right thing and after
all these years
redress this wrong we might finally get
to live up to this country's
highest potential and that is to become
a nation of rose and angie's
getting absolutely day wasted on our
porches
you